salve youtubers prima di iniziare questa
recensione vorrei ringraziarli
ringraziarvi tutti di cuore per i
commenti che ogni giorno lasciate per le
visualizzazioni che aumentano sempre di
più per esempio le visualizzazioni del
mio canale erano bloccate a 3.000 3.500
da quasi due anni da quando mi sono
iscritto su youtube
adesso in questo preciso momento sono
salita 13.500 e tutto grazie a voi ea
quanto pare perché i miei video vi
piacciono e non riesco a capire perché
perché voi credete che i miei video sono
divertenti io sono incazzato perché mi
fate vedere sti film del cavolo infatti
giocare a quei giochi orrendi ma poi
voglio dire quanto devi essere ubriaco
per pensare che quei video siano
divertenti
ringrazio anche tutti quelli che ogni
volta mi mandano un messaggio personale
consigliandomi qualche film da recensire
però una cosa consigliatevi film che non
siano dei capolavori perché qualcuno mi
consiglia spiderman 3 qualcuno vi
consiglia hicks mentre qua sono belli ma
cosa fate
rec e cloverfield sono belli the clover
t mettetevelo in testa
un ringraziamento particolare a quel
centinaio di migliaio di persone che mi
ha consigliato di recensire disaster
movie nomen omen dicevano i latini un
nome un destino disaster movie cioè io
né censito epic movie e poi avrei dovuto
recensire 300 ma non ci ho fatta ci
fanno schifo non saprei neanche cosa
dire fa schifo e basta e pieno di nulla
pieno di nulla e invece sono stato
costretto a guardare anche questo e vi
giuro che non so come ho fatto a
sopravvivere e come al solito eccovi la
lista delle cinque cose per cui disaster
movie fa schifo che potrebbero benissimo
essere cinque cose per cui dovrebbero
morire tutti i registi produttori attori
scenografi sceneggiatori microfonisti
aiutanti delle balle di questo film
numero 5 i primi due minuti
a me non piace giudicare un libro dalla
copertina tantomeno un film dalla
locandina
urca eva il meno di nomi venuti è
riuscito a farmi capire che questo film
era molto peggio di tutti gli altri
basta guardare
merda non voglio scheler aleggiare la
quinta posizione
andiamo avanti numero 4 musical ballo
chi ha detto ai produttori che fare una
gara di ballo e divertente non lo è
c'era in epic movie c'era il 300 c'è in
disaster movie non fa ridere perché
dovresti fare un hacker di mano non fa
ridere
qui come se non bastasse non c'è solo
una gara di ballo c'è anche un musical
un'intera canzone
[Musica]
che ancora ancora la canzone è
accettabile
io odio musical però la canzone dai e
orecchiabile peccato sia un film comico
numero tre battute troppo lunghe
già i produttori non sono riusciti a
capire che l'intero disaster movie tutte
le battute e le gag di disaster movie
non fanno ridere
figuriamoci prenderle battute peggiori e
le gag peggiori e prolungare
all'infinito
uno degli esempi più lampanti e la gag
di hannah montana continuate a darci
dentro
visto non è anche divertente in fondo
qual è la vostra i genitori ed i
comparti testino penetrando originale
diana lontana la grattugia diana montana
la carta igienica diana montana e mi
raccomando sintonizzatevi dicevo in
fondo qual è la caratteristica
principale di un film comico
il fatto di e voglio aggiungere una cosa
quelle foto super sexy e provocanti da
morire che mi ritraggono sono finite su
myspace assolutamente senza la mia
autorizzazione
ma fino tate
un altro esempio lampante guarda caso
nei primi due minuti e la scena del
rutto
[Musica]
ma quanto deve essere stupida demente la
gente per ridere di una scena del genere
male anche ai tempi di stanlio ollio ma
dai
potrei andare avanti all'infinito le
scene che le scelte e basta dai neanche
questa gang e simpatica basta le altre
silenzio le altre scene troppo lunghe
sono quelle del musical per esempio
delle scene di ballo sono troppo lunghe
non fanno ridere prossimo numero numero
due film presi in considerazione un film
parodia che un'unione di tante parodie e
giusto scegliere tra i film migliori
no ma quando parla non riescono a fare
neanche queste registi di sto film
voglio dire amy winehouse 11 come fai a
fare la parodia digiuno che l'ha visto
lo sarà è impossibile non ed azione non
è o non è non è niente è bellissimo giù
giù né bellissimo poi faccio una parodia
sopra high school musical
forse ci sto testando un po troppo sul
fatto nel musical però non fa ridere non
fa ridere e non fermi dovrebbe fare
vedere ma non fa ridere numero uno non
fa ridere non fa ridere non fa ridere io
l'ho detto nella recensione di epic
movie
cosa c'è di peggio di un film comico che
non fa ridere
epic movie no adesso c'è disaster movie
l impegno
epic movie e anche di 300 non c'è una
parte che si salva forse solo una la
scena di alvin superstar quella dove poi
partono con la musica metal i tre
criceti quella forse l'unica parte
decente tutto il resto è da prendere a
farlo trovare per bene e cliccare nella
gola dei registi produttori e la colpa
di tutto è vostra youtube che mi fate
vedere queste puttanate vi odio tutti